le stage va se dérouler donc sur trois
jours ou essentiellement le matin il y
aura beaucoup de tests et d'exercices
avec valence et ensuite les après midi
où là il y aura beaucoup de jeu et et
d'opposition pour avoir un maximum des
qualités des joueurs des antilles ont
accepté de venir encadrer ce stage parce
que tout simplement on se rend compte
que qu'à l'olympique de marseille en
termes de formation et des jeunes
joueurs et de bons potentiels notamment
des antilles martinique guadeloupe nous
ne profitons pas malheureusement de la
qualité de beaucoup de joueurs qui ont
pu sortir dans différents autres clubs
professionnels français est moins pas du
tout voir l'olympique de marseille
le dernier en date il me semble que
c'etait garry bocaly et on aimerait on
aimerait en avoir beaucoup plus
si la première année un premier concert
une détection et une équipe de l'art
histoire et comme nous sommes en zone
arctique de la guadeloupe et îles comme
le font les enfants voir énormément la
profité de l'occasion et pour organiser
cette détection pas pour faire vivre aux
enfants c'est uniquement les faits
revoir découvrir la façon de faire la
façon de voir
il va expliquer notamment comment ça se
passe on se gare dans vos boîtes unique
que les parents paient 15000 euros et
souvent après des années les enfants
sont de tous les bords du quai des
parentés d'une pratique votre peau et
ils sont les enfants les de football
parce qu'on les a pas fait comprendre
comment ça se passait on les a vérifiés
et tout le reste c'est annulé et là
c'est pas notre job l'objectif du club
c'est de faire découvrir quelque chose
qu'on puisse faire les enfants avancé
avec plus les moyens roulants mort
clinique